il ya des choses qui de mon point de vue
sont admissibles et d'autres qui ne le
sont pas donc moi j'attends de voir les
nations se réunir pour pouvoir décider
de l'avenir de ce rapport
c'est une position classique dans
laquelle les américains proposent un
certain nombre de choses à voir plus de
pouvoir dans lequel un certain nombre
d'européens s'aligne derrière les états
unis et où classiquement la france mène
le combat contre un certain nombre de
points
je n'imagine pas un seul instant que la
france accepte par exemple qui est pas
unanimité sur une décision parce que
dans ce cas là ça veut dire qu'elle
n'aurait plus le droit à la parole et
donc elle ne l'acceptera pas donc si
vous voulez il faut pas pleurer avant
d'avoir mal il faut voir quel est le
cheminement pris sa part ce rapport en
tout état de cause c'est une tendance
générale de de l'otan d'essayer
d'élargir son champ d'action et c'est
pour ça que maintenant il élargit à
l'asie en particulier ils demandent de
l'élargir à l'asie et jusqu'à maintenant
tout ceci c'est toujours traités dans ce
qu'on appelait le partenariat pour la
paix dire que les gens qui font pas
partie de l'otan'' mais qu'on associe
alors on les associe à des réflexions
les associe pas ou décisions c'est le
cas également des australiens et des néo
zélandais par exemple qui ne sont pas
associés aux décisions
donc je pense que la position va
continuer avec celle là pour la france
c'est qu'il ya dedans dès de manière
générale c'est une intrusion de plus en
plus grande et jusque dans les moindres
détails de l'organisation elle même au
temps qui s'appelle autant avec son
secrétaire général
stoltenberg pour en fait imposer la
stratégie américaine au sein de l'europe
et ses salles immenses danger on dépasse
d'abord le principe de consensus entre
les états lorsque il est dit que pacy
encore de consensus
on se mettra d'accord entre quelques
états et puis on fera l'opération qu'on
a envie de faire
même si certains états n'ont pas envie
donc vous voyez il ya ça c'est un des
détails un des dix ou douze points qui a
mis
tous les points vont dans le sens d'une
centralisation de plus en plus grande
qui dolls là les rênes de cette
organisation aux stratèges américains et
qui fait que et qu'ils ont renforcé
l'idée que la russie est un ennemi
blague l'europe et que la bataille se
fera sur le sol européen
bien sûr on peut on peut réformer tout à
fait je rappelle que dans le ja budget
commun qui est qui et quand même quelque
chose de relativement réduit l'essentiel
des moyens sont des moyens nationaux
donc les gens confondent souvent parfois
les 2% de pib de chacun des pays
ça c'est leur part à eux qui concourent
à leur défense à eux et par ailleurs il
ya la part du budget commun qui est
effectivement peut être réduit le
problème de l'otan et de se trouver en
permanence d une raison d'exister et en
particulier un budget important lui
donne une raison d'exister donc très
certainement ça peut être vu un certain
nombre de points peuvent être vues sur
le budget commun dans le temps c'était
une organisation pernicieuse qui empêche
la création d'une europe des nations
solide d'une europe puissance et donc il
faut sortir de cette organisation non
pas dire qu'on a un ennemi des états
unis on reste un allié des états unis
dont on sort de cette organisation
militaire qui est ni plus ni moins que
la mainmise des états unis sur l'europe
et on peut comprendre certains pays
anciennement dans l'orbité soviétique de
cette jetée dans les bras des américains
disent en maintenant notre sécurité
avant c'était moscou maintenance et les
états unis et on est bien plus heureux
comme ça mais ce goulet la france c'est
pas du tout son rôle en europe n'est pas
du tout de prendre de cette attitude de
dire je m'en remet entièrement aux
américains pour la défense des intérêts
de la france donc moi je suis partisan
d'une sorte ni ni plus ni moins de
lorgues
lisa sion intégré de l'otan
tu avais le problème mais pas aussi
simple qu'il y paraît car de façon
caricaturale la défense européenne ce a
su avec les européens et la position de
la france que souligne colette corrèze
et comme connais bien n'est pas la
position des jeunes européens
donc on peut faire la défense européenne
sans les européens c'est un choix mais à
mon avis un peu de chances de progresser
notre gros problème c'est de faire de la
pédagogie vis-à-vis des européens c'est
de leur expliquer que la menace russe
n'est plus ce qu'elle était que la
menace est plus au sud et qu'il faut
qu'ils nous rejoignent